hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie sorry about the late start today
had some troubleshooting issues with our
bulletin app that we're excuse me we're
working on converting into react but we
did not launch that yet we also wanted
to make that a mobile app and a desktop
app using react native and electron so
we haven't gotten to that yet kind of
wish we would have and then I wouldn't
have to have this troubleshooting we
wouldn't have users with issues the
latest issue was someone is using Safari
and it's supposed to store some data and
local storage so that you don't have to
log in every time you should stay logged
in for an entire year if you go through
the password this login process which is
a magic link sent by email but
unfortunately it's not working so I've
been emailing back and forth trying to
figure out what's happening it is the
latest version of Safari which is great
and now I'm trying to confirm the
privacy settings as it's possible the
privacy settings are very strict and
it's not allowing local storage to work
I'm hoping that that's the issue because
if it's not I'm out of ideas
and I'll probably have to go to this
person's office and check the computer
myself so hopefully I'll get an email
back about that sometime very soon and
for today's stream I'm gonna do some
things with with cookies we could use
local storage for this I guess it
depends on what we want to do but I
think cookies will be sufficient and
we're gonna track whether or not a user
has been to our site before if they have
been to the site before we're going to
show them a different configuration of
the homepage then if this is their first
time so let me show you
the homepage first explain what needs to
change and why and then we'll get into
some of the code I do want to say thank
you to those of you that submitted pull
requests over the weekend I've been busy
this morning and I have not gotten to
review those pull requests but just a
little bit that I did see everything
looks great so I really appreciate that
in a stream later this week I'll go over
all this pool requests and and thank you
all properly
let's see also Harshit finished changing
over the resource center project into an
electron app so I'm running this now on
a Mac so you can see this is it's all
working I can download things from here
I can send forms actually haven't tried
to send the form yet but I'm I think
Harsha tried and it did work so yes so
this all works as it should which is
awesome so I'm gonna do a little bit
more testing about that and then
hopefully get that out to users as an
option so they'll heal her should also
finish the react native app as well but
I think that when I tried on an Android
phone the download feature wasn't
working so we'll have to work on that
but it'd be nice to offer our users the
option of having the mobile app or the
desktop app instead of having to rely on
their browser and that'll really help
users that are having some browser
issues with privacy settings or with
using an older browser then they won't
have to worry about it all right I don't
think I've I had a few things to
announce I don't think I skipped
anything oh the only other thing I
wanted to say at the beginning which is
just kind of a fun silly thing so I have
purchased the domain name JavaScript AF
I'm not gonna explain the dot AF part of
it if you know then you'll I guess
understand why that's kind of funny
other
I guess you could look it up but I
thought it would just be a cool domain
to have but I'm not really sure what I
want to do with it so I don't know if
you'll have any ideas for what type of
content should be on JavaScript AF let
me know because I I'd like to put
something cool on there related to
JavaScript and have it be useful so yeah
I don't know and if I guess if anybody
really wants that domain I could just
sell it but I I mean I if I can make
some money off that that would be cool I
guess but it would also be really cool
to actually have a like a useful site
Harshit says alert you can't run
CloudFlare on AF domains this is bad
it hurts to sell it to west boss he has
basta si yeah maybe maybe someone will
just want to buy it maybe I'll just put
it out there on Twitter that I have it
if anybody wants it we'll see maybe that
could be my personal portfolio side do
you think potential employers would
think that's funny or would they would
that turn them off all right let's see I
think sorry I thought I got an email
back already about that that issue but
it looks like my phone is just behind is
getting some old emails
okay
all right so enough of that let's get
started oh I'll go back through when we
take our break and reach some warrior
suggestions as well and let's see oh I
was gonna show you the site first okay
let's do that I have it up on my other
screen somewhere here we are okay so I
made the last time we were working on
this we had done this right so that's
still there I'm working on adding in a
form so that users can request us a
mentor training session so I've put in
all the server code for setting up a
route for that form to go to and then
sending it via send grid so I made a new
API key if you're interested in learning
more about that we did a stream on it
earlier so you can go back through the
title should be something like using the
same grid API something like that and
the code is now on the up the upgrade
branch so I haven't merged this in the
master yet so if you check out the repo
in the upgrade branch the last commit
was all the code that I added for this
so that's available if you want it but
today we're going to be working on the
home page I'll probably finish up the
form later today after the stream
assuming I have time so this is what
users currently see every user sees this
what we're going to change is we're
going to keep it like this for new users
and then if the user is a returned user
we're gonna bring this section up and
we're going to display this section as
the first section and then the video
will be below it so it shouldn't be too
difficult probably the most difficult
part would just be tracking the user
especially if
if you've never worked with cookies or
local storage or anything like that but
I don't think it's going to be a big
deal I think we'll get this we'll get
through this in today's street so let's
get to it
let me bring over my plum adoro timer
and we'll start it off if you're asking
the questions in the live chat now I
will get to the questions so just hang
on for about 25 minutes and then I'll go
back to the questions and answer as many
as I can I can also start and grow up
and I'm gonna paste a link into the live
chat if you follow that link you can see
the site as we're working on it when I
change something you will see the change
you can inspect it with dev tools
alright so this was some of the service
stuff I was working on let's make it
bigger and then move to our our home
page index all right I can move this
over a bit and let me know if that's
large enough so this our own page and
for right now we're gonna do everything
in this component just to save time
might not be a bad idea to make you know
kind of a utility component to use but
for now this will work what I here's my
plan
what I think we'll do is in component
did mount will check to see will check
cookies I'm gonna try to do it with
cookies I think but we could do with
local storage let me know in the live
chat if you see a benefit
doing one over the other or if it just
doesn't matter I don't really know if
there would be any difference between
them
I know local storage you can put more
data in but we really don't need any any
data probably just your true or false is
all we need
but anyway the idea is on component did
amount we're gonna check and then based
on that I suppose we'll just change our
state we'll just add some state here and
we'll change the state and then
depending on that we can change the
position of there's this video but
probably this yeah this whole section
this whole div section will just change
so we can probably should make this its
own component if we're going to do that
we don't need to if we're just testing
but then at some point it would be good
to maybe split this out into its own
component so it's not taking up so much
space especially since we're gonna
basically double it
Harshit said cookies would get sent to
the server which is not required okay
maybe we'll do maybe we'll do local
storage and yeah which is cool I'm
actually more familiar with using local
storage than I am with with cookies the
harsh it says cookies often get cleared
okay all right so let's create a
function which check user status
[Music]
it's
how do I always forget to do a how to do
an arrow function every time like this
why I use arrow functions constantly
there we go that's why I just forget the
order
I've been forgetting weird things lately
like yesterday I forgot how to tie a tie
for a few minutes I was just and I've
known how to tie a tie for years I'm
like a slightly afraid and probably
irrationally afraid that I have like
Alzheimer's starting or something
because it does run in my family so now
I'm I'm worried about it I really hope
that that's not the case I'm only 32 is
that even impossible all right so we
have the check user status function now
and we're going to check local storage
all right I do want to do this in a way
that to make sure that it doesn't try to
do this hmm
I don't want it to try to do this server
side because we are doing server-side
rendering so what does to only happen
client-side
actually alright I wonder about this so
let me know in the live chat if this is
not the right way to think about this
but users are likely to come to index
dodge is the home page first right so
that's where they're gonna get a
server-side rendered version of this
page so we'll component did mount even
run in the browser
okay harsh it says component did mount
does not run on server your right hard
[ __ ] you know what I don't know why I
was thinking that I mean we're logging a
page view here weird initializing the
tabs and this most definitely runs so
all right I don't know what I was
thinking there but this will work so
we're good okay so we're gonna check
user status and we'll put that in here
as well so that will run and we're gonna
do let's just put some some comments
here it's gonna be checked check local
storage or user let's see if true then
display news first
user to local stores and set state to
false okay so let's let's actually this
make state C return user so the default
is actually going to be true I guess it
doesn't matter what we make the default
I was making the default true but that's
just how I wrote it here okay
uh Hersh it says this does make users
does oh okay thank you hard [ __ ] I
forgot to write this dot check user
status right because these two were
importing if you see where he's coming
in blog page view and I'm porting an in
tab strong I guess I'm not importing and
it's just running in a separate
JavaScript file but anyway that's why I
can just do log page view without this
but since we're defining this in here
and then we're gonna use this if we end
up making this its own component then or
a utility function then we can take out
this but for now good catch on that are
[ __ ] okay so let's write some of that
let's see
local storage when you have to get item
so how it goes tricky
user
returned user is true actually thing we
don't need to do anything right we may
as well do it set the state to true yeah
because the user could navigate around
and come back so I guess we'll do that
you know what I'm gonna use a regular if
statement for this true then say this
it's states
either that's true
I need to do this
that's good and then else
oops
and we need to do the local stores local
storage set oops
set item and we're gonna say return user
so no we do it gonna be
okay
okay
let's see all right so we're good there
let's grab this
why did I do that there that's not what
I needed
let's bring this here so we still need
this to be so either way we're gonna set
it to be true afterwards but if it's
false so this else means it was false
we're gonna add this here so up here we
don't need to obviously because if it
already found it okay that's good let's
see Harshit saying there's a syntax
error so have a syntax error somewhere
am I supposed to put is it this is
supposed to be a string yeah yeah okay
okay that's supposed to be a string and
I think this is actually supposed to be
a string - whoops okay
okay in the set stage is correct
okay heart should sing that I should
wrap the wrap the string in a json.parse
okay
where which one do I have to wrap in a
json.parse
essentially I'm not even actually
worried about what the value of return
user is because if it's false it's just
not even going to be there at all so I
just need to know if it exists so if
that's the case I'm not sure that I I
need to put well I mean at this point
they ought to just try it out yes then
at least it'll be easier for me to see
with what the problems are so for now we
can just check our state and dev tools
to see what's happening before we do
anything in the UI okay it looks like
there's still a problem on line 33 all
right what do I have
alright Sim Sim Renji what's what's the
problem with line 33
so this would be line 33 here
all right oh the me window dot local
storage
so what's the problem with windowed
local storage
alright let's just save it and then did
you see that Harsha did you see it it
updated on save it formatted finally got
that working thank you for that okay so
let's check out hey awesome didn't get
any errors very cool and let's go into
dev tools and this will be cool if
you've never done any troubleshooting
with react and chrome dev tools I'll
show you how to get to it so you can get
the react dev tools so I don't even
remember how to get this for Chrome to
be honest with you I wish I did cuz I'd
like to tell you but it was too long ago
that I got it
so check out the react dev tools I'm
sure you'll it'll be high up in the
search results
alright so yeah - no let me make this
bigger you all probably can't see
anything alright so let me expand this
we don't need this down here okay so you
can see here this looks like your normal
your layout of dev tools except these
are all the components right so we do
see some things like headers and divs
and all that but normally in dev tools
you wouldn't see all the component names
as you can see here we this is our like
root component and we can go all the way
down here's our layout and let's find
our
trying to find our main component here
it's a suit
maybe not
some trying to understate see where I
stay loose
to speak what did we call this component
now it's just export default it's just
index
No
I remember we call this maybe I will
have to do something in the UI since I
can't seem to find my state
let's see this should be
I had enough we should be somewhere
between the nav main it's not where it's
gonna be no heroes all right
so this is weird I cannot I cannot find
the state for that it's possible I'm
doing something wrong it happens
frequently all right
all right harsh it says it is the class
one that's what I thought it would be
but oh my goodness how did I not see
that harshly good job again I'm pretty
sure we click that one before
anyway I must have just been clicking
too fast all right cool so you can see
our stake for return user is true which
is wonderful and now we can even check
in local storage and return user is true
wonderful so now we should be able to go
in here do whatever you want to do with
the UI and let me check my time two
minutes we'll see what I can do in two
minutes actually let's see if I can get
this to work in two minutes I don't
really think I can but it'll be fun just
to try to do this quickly okay so here's
our div and we want to now wrap this div
in a ternary that's gonna say this state
return user and if it's true then we're
going to render this section
nope I'm not if it's false I'm going to
render this section so let's say the
state return user if it's true we're
actually going to render the news if
it's false we're gonna render this
section so let's grab the news down here
news announcements
okay early yet there we are
it's at this stiff
it's just
think it's this one
thanks you okay just copy that and put
it here and then down here we're gonna
do another ternary and that's gonna be
if this state return user is not equal
to true what the heck am i doing if if
this state return user so if this day
return user is false
then we're gonna and then we're gonna
render this stuff actually
this would be so much faster okay let's
save it aha I couldn't do it
adjacent elements must be wrapped in a
closed inside looks like I maybe took
one too many divs
we're not enough let's pour a div out
and see what happens
what did I do
oh well my timer went off will
troubleshoot this after we talk about
this so oh well it was fun it was fun to
try to do it quickly five minutes in the
live chat and then we'll go back to it
and figure out what I messed up I think
the logic was okay it was just I messed
up something with the closing tag a lot
of you were saying hi so hey everyone
thanks for watching alright real Vignesh
says document dot get element by ID some
ID inner HTML equals enter HTML plus one
can you please explain this statement it
looks like somebody was explaining so
Dimitri says if inner HTML was a
variable then yes
this one
yeah I'm I'm actually not
so you're trying to set the innerhtml of
an element with the idea of some ID all
right so there's a few things that are
weird about that so the some ID has a
space there I'm I'm not exactly sure you
could do that like it would have to be
all together or there's a hyphen in
between and then is inter HTML really
capitalized like I is capitalized and
HTML it could be I just I always thought
it would just be lowercase I anyway and
then inner HTML plus 1 so normally like
what would happen there basically is
inner HTML would come up as you're using
it there it seems like it's a variable
so it will come up as enter HTML zonda
fine unless you've defined in or HTML
earlier and if you've done that then
saying dot inner HTML in your document
dot get element by ID is is probably I
mean I guess it would still work so if
inner HTML is already defined as a
variable beforehand and it's a number
then that would just increase the number
by one if it's a string you would just
get the number one concatenated onto the
end of it correct I don't know if
anybody in the live chat can see that
and has a different answer let me know
but I think real Vignesh if you're still
there
and you have like a larger code sample
that might help or if you have any
response to any of that to clarify that
might help
all right so here are some ideas for my
JavaScript AF domain
let's see cloud says maybe fun little
code snippets sub in says add cool
JavaScript tutorial or should horseshit
said sell to west boss Pedro says Don AF
is Afghanistan yeah got AF is
Afghanistan
Clause says that could sell for a lot
yeah maybe if it I mean at first I just
wanted to buy it because I thought it
was fun but yeah you're right I mean
maybe someone will want it maybe it'll
sell for a lot I just tell them it means
at Franciscan yeah that's what I'll tell
people at work that it means at
Franciscan
Andy says react is a good choice but I
prefer angular for single page
applications
I think angular is good - I haven't
really worked with the newer versions of
angular at all though but I mean a lot
of companies and good Deb's use it so
I'm sure it's a good option as well
John Hanson says doesn't it matter more
to what each user expects to see as
their personal view of the site cookies
set this up easier than doing this in
react which may still need a call to the
server I'm not sure let's see how this
works and see if there's problems with
it and it we can always switch back over
to cookies if we need to okay him Anshu
asks what init tabs means all right
let's go back we might as well start
this again now we're getting back to the
code anyway so here we have a knit tabs
this is simply a JavaScript function
that I have in another file and all it
does is it initializes our tab system
which we can't see now I can show you in
the live site actually so we have our
tabs here so it enables this now this
seems really weird in react and it is
really weird I don't recommend doing
this but this is run by jQuery that's
why we did it like that and it is not
ideal and I'd love to switch it over to
something more proper to react at some
point but right now I just need to get
this done as quickly as possible so I
can get back to the main website project
and have that done very soon so that's
what it attaches though so I'm gonna get
back to the project if I can find a pen
I know that I don't have a pen anywhere
I need a friend of hence I can write
down where I left off sorry I guess it's
not gonna happen because I don't have a
pen all right
blitz
let's figure out what I did wrong so it
looks like I messed something up with
these divs so here's our index this is
getting huge
we will refactor this at some point
hopefully maybe because this is just way
too too large all right so here's our
main let's scroll all the way up and see
what we have
after main here just say main main all
right so it should be fine that
stickiness
that's humanity where's the end of
stickiness
oh there's the end of sticky nevets it's
a self-closing tag all right okay so
let's make sure we have this close
properly we have this div
oh this is yeah okay that's closing this
out that's fine
Oh
I think I needed an extra div there okay
so I need an extra div there and so down
here let's make sure I have the right
dose
now it looks like I need take these two
divs out we put them here let's save it
now yay all right cool hmm oops I messed
up in my logic all right so this is cool
so this works it's up here and then down
here we don't have anything so that part
works the part I messed up with in my
logic was we still want the video to
show up we just want it to be below so
let's go up to where we did that and
what we want
really what we can do is completely take
this video out of here
here we are there's more videos so let's
take the video out and put the video
here and then I'll clean this up a bit
and what we need to do here is say this
state return user then we're going to
render that this is a little short
circuit for your ternary there we are so
now we should see a wonderful so we have
the news right off the bat then we have
our video and then the rest of the page
wonderful this works good now let's test
out what happens whenever we go back to
being a new user just to make sure so we
can go into react and we can go back to
our component and let's change this to
false and now let's see what our page
looks like there we are
so you can see now we've changed it to
false manually and here's how our page
looks and this is at the bottom whoa
all right you know what that this isn't
working only because we changed it
manually because it needs component yeah
so let's let's refresh so this works now
and these do work and let me go
I'm gonna use my let's use an incognito
window to go to the same place
why did it see that
look willows should not persist in
incognito correct
all right we bring up an entirely
different browser hmm I think I may have
messed something up because here in
Safari we have the same thing all right
let's take a look back here what we're
doing so we're gonna check user status
if the get item returned user is there
at least that's what I thought it was
gonna be
oh I never mind
all right let's try this
try a new incognito window there we are
okay all right let me explain what I had
done that that was just silly so what I
was doing was I was setting the state to
true no matter what
so if returnin user did exist in local
storage we're setting it to true which
is correct but then if it didn't exist
we're still setting the state to true
which is not what we wanted right what I
had done I believe was copy and pasted
this from here and never change the
value so we want to set this to false
but then afterwards set our local
storage to true now what I want to do is
test this out again here let's still
check ok all right so this is working
and let's double check in another
browser so I'm gonna put a firefox this
time make sure it all works so let's go
I don't know there we go
3,000 all right good so first time we're
here we're seeing this and now that's
let's go to an interior page and then
let's come back great now we're return
user right we've come back to this page
again and now we have our other view
wonderful alright cool so we verified it
works we've gotten it to load on three
different browsers awesome ok so I'm not
the the holo
reasoning behind knowing it like this is
that the the people who are doing this
site for really wanted users when they
come back to immediately see what's new
what's going on so that's why they
wanted this here but they really really
liked this video this video explains
what this thing is all about so they
wanted a nice introduction for new
people but then they want to return
users to be able to see this so that's
when I there was a debate about what
section to put at the top and I said
well I mean we could just switch it
based on whether the users been here
already or not so that's why we ended up
going with this jammed up being good
because then we didn't have to debate it
anymore we could move on to other stuff
so anyway that was the point of this it
works which is great and we got it done
pretty quickly so not bad I mean I don't
want to make myself sound really good
but I'm just like I'm happy when things
work out so quickly it's I'm happy about
that alright so let's go let me go to
the live chat and I'll have have some
time to answer some questions so if you
have any questions please put them in
the live chat now
and that's I can remember where it left
off here all right I found it
Muhammad says hello how's it going
thanks for watching Muhammad says all I
know is basic basic HTML but I'm a 3d
modeler so I don't feel guilty
so that wish I could learn this yeah
well Muhammad feel free to ask as many
questions as you want here I'll do my
best to answer them
and if you need me to go over something
again I mean I can do that sorry
alright there's a lot of talk about
whether or not I was writing these
functions correctly got it oh that's
just hey tech says today's question is
using cookies in JavaScript yeah
basically we were I was thinking we
would use cookies but we end up using
local storage which is easy either local
storage is easier anyway so that works
maybe I'll go back and change the title
to local storage
it's sec a stood
I'm using Visual Studio code today to my
earlier videos I used atom a lot and now
I've switched over to the s code they're
both really good Lucas says hi Jesse my
name is Lucas and I'm from Brazil I I
like so much your your live your code is
very good awesome thank you thank you
for saying that I really appreciate that
see Brooke says hi oh just got back from
[Music]
kanessa therapy what did I miss
can easily repeat I don't know how to
pronounce that type of therapy but
anyway I'm glad you're back rook I hope
everything's going well with your
therapy basically we just saved some
data to local storage we just wanted to
know whether or not a user has been
there or not so we really just could
save anything we wanted to local storage
and just check to see if there is
anything in local storage for this
domain and then based on that we show
the sections on the front page in a
different order
sumon says Wow how do you maintain such
a huge file I do the same thing to ya
right now the file is larger than I
would like so it's just it's just it
makes it difficult the larger the file
gets the more difficult I think is to
keep in your head where everything is so
it's just like extra cognitive load on
your mind so I think smaller files are
much easier to deal with so there are a
few areas in this file right now where
we could refactor and make it a lot
smaller so I think that's that would be
good to do maybe I'll put that in as an
issue in the github repo and if
anybody's interested you can take a shot
at refactoring to be honest with you I'm
probably not gonna take the time to
refactor right now because I need to get
back to my other project so this will be
something at least for my to do this
this will be something that's like hey
if you ever have some time where you
don't have anything that's due like
right now go back and refactor this
sathya says hey how about a session on
material UI next with react is material
UI next a thing or are you saying like
material you I and next with react so we
have done some sessions on material UI
and next we're going to be we're going
to continue working with material James
says is this to show how to make a
cookie yeah well we ended up going with
local storage so local stories
essentially does pretty much the same
things as cookies doing in some sites
I'm not saying they are the same but
they are used in the same use cases
frequently so we ended up going with
local storage - not exactly cookies
although in some browsers if you go to
empty the cookies it actually empties
out local storage
well which is odd I think maybe like
Internet Explorer does that and maybe
like if you use CCleaner on Windows and
you go to empty out the I think it's
cookies I can't remember for sure but I
have come across before that local
storage gets lumped into the category of
cookies which is kind of misleading I
guess but sometimes that does happen
I know says hello everybody hey how's it
going
yes
all right I've got a question here in
another language ready to google
translate that let's see
all right so I think maybe my Google
Translate is not working properly
because it says that the attend read
just said what is India doing in the hey
so I I'm not really sure I think I the
translated it doesn't seem correct so so
let me know what that that was really
supposed to mean
yet and rrah so it says the language is
Hindi so if anybody knows Hindi you can
let me know Sathya says just fold the
code they copy them oh that would have
been such a good idea okay I got a
customer service Co here
hello yeah yeah hey how are you oh yeah
definitely
so I'm when you come in the marketing
department and you you make immediately
make a left and I'm the first office
there it'll say okay
yeah yeah go to the middle down by the
the seminar room and then there's that
door to go into marketing and
development everything yep and I'm first
order left my name will be on there all
right no problem
all right so that's cool so the
professor that was having trouble with
the bulletin is gonna bring his laptop
over here which is awesome because
normally I have to go find other people
at their office and I I do that just
yeah the courtesy you know I say hey you
know my sites not working I'll come help
you
just as soon as for dinner all right
let's see
all right you all Michael and hard [ __ ]
you all saw my my problem before I did
so thanks for that I should just looked
over let's see
ash says I thought this project was done
yeah it it was done and launched but
then we had a meeting and there were
some updates that they wanted so
basically like they're adding some
things on that they didn't have before
so offerings like they have his mentor
training going on and they I guess
they've gotten some feedback had some
new ideas so there's a series of updates
that are gonna happen some of them need
to happen right now some of them can
wait until later and are a little bit
more complicated so I'm just gonna do
the updates that need to be done right
now I'm gonna try to do them now so we
can move back into our other project
which to be honest with you is is more
important right now because it's going
to serve a lot more users so it's tough
to tell you know a client or somebody
like hey I got other projects that are
more important because everybody thinks
their projects is important which is
it's important to them it's true but I
want to do at least do something so that
I can so we can get some of the features
on this site first and then move it over
so today I'll probably be working on
this site and then maybe tomorrow after
I want to be done with it all I will
probably have to wait on some feedback
and content from them so I can't
actually get this stuff live as soon as
I want that's but that's kinda how it is
I that's how it always is you know if
you don't have the content you can't
really launch
Harshit says there is a delay in
switching the views for new users as CDM
is not fired immediately use my method
all right so hard saying change default
state to false and remove set state from
else and change default state the Falls
all right let's see
they were react all right so remove this
and then make the default state false
okay I like that we got rid of two lines
of one minor code just verified still
gonna work yeah it still works
open up incognito window oh yeah yeah
just go in have a seat
okay I'm doing a live show here so I'm
just gonna finish it up oh it's nice you
brought me some beer good didn't have
money to go all right everyone so I have
a professor here who I'm gonna help out
with some issues with that bulletin
project that we were working on before
and anyway so uh I think I got to
everybody's question on how I see your
question you know what send me a direct
message on Twitter or can you put that
question in the comments and I will get
to that I'll answer that sometime today
and anybody else who has a question that
I can't get to right now go ahead and
just send me a DM or put in the comments
so anyway thank you so much for watching
I appreciate all the help it definitely
saved me a lot of time I will be back
tomorrow around 12 p.m. Eastern time and
until then have a great day